today the Matt Walsh show Joe Biden
makes the worst trade deal in history
bringing an anti-American WNBA player
home in exchange for notorious Russian
arms dealer but the real problem is the
people he left behind to talk about that
also the dean at a Swanky private school
is caught on tape bragging about giving
his students sex toys to play with of
course the school is standing behind him
and trans Tick-Tock star Dylan Mulvaney
lectures women for failing to appreciate
his tampon-related charitable acts lots
of weird things happening today we'll
talk about it all and much more on the
Matt Walsh show
foreign
if we're going to change the culture and
dominance of large corporations that
actively work to quiet our beliefs we
need to reassess our spending habits and
start supporting like-minded companies
that's why you need to switch to the
pro-life pro-family cell phone company
Charity mobile Charity mobile has the
same great Nationwide mobile phone
service and coverage as other carriers
and they spend five percent of your
monthly plan price plan price for the
pro-life pro-family charity of your
choice you don't have to compromise on
value or service Charity mobile offers
the latest phones and tablets and Live
customer service based in the US the
midterm elections made clear that the
fight for the right to life will
continue for unborn children pro-life
causes need your continued support and
so charity Mobile's special Christmas
promotion is more important than ever
includes a free phone free activation
free shipping and a free portable
battery charger for new customers while
supplies last all you gotta do is
mention code Walsh call
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com mention offer code
Walsh that's charitymobile.com
and code Walsh
so to steal a joke from Twitter that's
already gotten old in like 15 minutes
this is the first time a WNBA trade has
made headlines the bite Administration
announced this morning that Brittany
Greiner has is on her way home after her
release was secured in a one-for-one
prisoner swap with Russia the daily wire
has more on us as a WNBA star Brittany
Greiner was freed from Russian captivity
Thursday in a prisoner exchange for
notorious Russian arms dealer President
Joe Biden announced Greiner who was
arrested in February at a Moscow airport
after being caught with marijuana vaping
materials
was sentenced in August to nine years in
prison the six foot nine inch athlete
plays for the uh wnba's Phoenix Mercury
okay I just learned I just learned just
now what team she plays for so that's
what it is and had flown to Russia to
finish her season for wmmc uh when she
was arrested U.S diplomats have been
scrambling to win her release but the
efforts were complicated about Russia's
International isolation as a result of
its invasion of Ukraine the US agreed to
the swap for arms dealer Victor bout an
international criminal known as The
Merchant of death so
we get a WNBA player most famous for
pushing the WNBA to stop playing the
national anthem before games a player
who has said
that that she will not come out onto the
court if her country's Anthem is being
played a woman who has managed to earn a
pretty handsome living in this country
while playing in an obscure Sports
League that only exists because the NBA
acts as its sugar daddy propping it up
and keeping it afloat a woman who has a
net worth in the millions and yet nobody
had ever heard of
until she tried to sneak drug
paraphernalia through a Russian Airport
that's like the most famous play she's
ever been a part of would you try to
pass drug material through an airport in
Russia
um this woman who who has every reason
to love and be grateful for America but
instead hates and resents it
we get her we get her back and then
Russia gets one of the most notorious
arms dealers in history that's the trade
this makes the Browns giving up three
first-round draft picks and 250 million
guaranteed for DeSean Watson seemed like
a brilliant deal in comparison
and by the way if you want to know a
little bit more about the man that we
just sent back to Russia CBS News has
some details about that it says about a
former Soviet military translator turned
International arms dealer has been
imprisoned for more than a decade after
he was lured to Thailand in a Drug
Enforcement Administration sting
operation that spanned three continents
quote Victor bout in my eyes is one of
the most dangerous men on the face of
the Earth Michael Braun former chief
chief of operations for the U.S Drug
Enforcement Administration told 60
Minutes in 2010. in 1995 he was 28. he
began spending time at cargo hangers in
sharjah's international airport in the
United Arab Emirates eventually
launching his cargo airlines air sess
with a small Fleet of Russian planes
that delivered goods to Africa and
Afghanistan in the years that followed
bout helped fuel Civil Wars across the
world by supplying more sophisticated
weapons sometimes to both sides of the
bloody conflicts quote if I didn't do it
someone else would about told the New
Yorker that was his excuse for that was
his rationale by then he was on the
radar of U.S and British officials Peter
Hayne the minister of State for Africa
and Britain's foreign office sounded the
alarm as British soldiers in Africa came
under attack by increasingly
sophisticated weapons
quote sanction Busters are continuing to
perpetuate the conflict in Sierra Leone
and Angola with the result that
countless lives are being lost and
mutilations are taking place Victor bout
is indeed the chief sanctions Buster and
is a merchant of death who owns air
companies that ferry in arms and other
logistics support for the rebels in
Angola and Sierra Leone and take out the
diamonds which pay for the arms aiding
and abetting people who are turning
their guns on British soldiers that
according to hang
so a very expensive and complex
operation was launched
to lure bout out of Russia and arrest
him
and it was eventually successful he was
convicted of conspiracy to kill U.S
citizens and officials uh delivery of
anti-aircraft missiles and providing Aid
to a terrorist organization that was
what he was convicted of sentenced to 25
years in prison
which on its own to me seems pretty
light
but he's not gonna have to serve it he's
not gonna have to serve all of it or
even most of it because he's going home
and we get Brittany Greiner
there's something else being left out
here rather someone being left up Paul
Whalen is a former U.S marine who's been
imprisoned in Russia for four years now
starting back in 2018 on what our
government says our baseless Espionage
charges now it was expected at least by
the people dumb enough to have any faith
in this Administration it was expected
by them that he would be a part of any
trade or prisoner swap involving
Brittany Greiner there will be a package
deal at a minimum
but instead he's been left to rot he's
left out of the deal Biden is taking
Greiner
leaving Wayland
Biden did address that issue very
briefly in his remarks earlier about
about this deal and here's what he said
she wrote to me back in July
she didn't ask for special treatment
even though we've been working on a
release from the day one she requested a
simple quote please don't forget about
me and the other American detainees
please do all you can to bring us home
we never forgot about Brittany we've not
forgotten about Paul Whalen who's been
unjustly detained in Russia for years
this was not a choice of which American
to bring home
we brought home Trevor Reed when we had
a chance early this year
sadly for totally illegitimate reasons
Russia is treating Paul's case
differently than Britney's and while we
have not yet succeeded in securing
Paul's release we are not giving up we
will never give up
uh Russia is treating Paul Whalen
differently yeah
it's not to buy an Administration that
has made Brittany Greiner a priority
for political and PR reasons
but they're not giving up he says
they're not going to give up on Paul
Whalen but but they are giving up on him
they did because they gave up the best
leverage that they have
there was only one as far as I'm aware
Russian arms trafficker called The
Merchant of death in a U.S prison and
Biden just surrendered him for the pot
smoking female basketball player
it is truly an Abomination I mean he
left the Marine behind and saved the
WNBA player it's one of the most
shameful things I've ever seen a U.S
president do in my lifetime and if you
know anything about U.S presidents over
the past 35 years that is uh saying
quite a lot
now I admit I am I am somewhat biased
here okay I'm not entirely objective
because I'm biased first of all in favor
of Marines over WNBA players for one
thing I'm biased in favor of National
Security which we have now compromised
by releasing a man that our own
government has said is one of the most
dangerous people on the planet
but I'm also biased because I never felt
I got to be honest with you
call me cruel I never felt all that
sorry for Brittany Greiner in the first
place
um Russia didn't fabricate the charges
against her
she did in fact attempt to bring drug
paraphernalia into Moscow that's she did
that
she broke the laws of the country she
was visiting
and uh
you know just so happens that it's a
country that doesn't have a lot of
tolerance for drug use
okay we have a lot of tolerance for drug
use in our country way too much
tolerance but not every country is like
the United States
um I I have been traveling recently uh
in in in and through countries with
different laws and policies than our own
and I realized when I was there that I'm
at their mercy and I have to play by
their rules if I'm not willing to do
that then I'm not going to go
now
doesn't mean that I would you know if it
was up to me that I would leave her to
spend years in a labor camp because of
it rather it means that
because of her own stupid and Reckless
Behavior
because of our own ego that made her
believe that she was exempt from Russian
law she she had put herself in this
position
and she should have been left to suffer
the consequences until a deal that
serves America's interests and includes
Paul Whalen could be reached
after all she was only arrested months
ago Whalen was arrested years ago so if
he can keep waiting then so can she
but Biden wasn't thinking about American
interests or national security nor was
he concerned with Justice or fairness
instead he made his decision according
to the dictates of left-wing
intersectionality
a game that Whalen will always lose when
up against Brittany Greiner
Bernie Greiner uh
lesbian black female
they just as far as the by
Administration is concerned there is no
contest here
so he did what was best for public
relations also note incidentally and
this is one thing we shouldn't
allowed Escape our notice that uh the
the very Administration that rant so
much about the dangers of gun violence
has just released the most notorious gun
runner in history
so the hypocrisies here are endless
but
though this may be hypocritical though
though it may be a disgrace though it
may be the worst basketball related
trade since the Bucks gave Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar to the Lakers though it may
compromise National Security at least
one might hope
it will give the anti-American Brittany
Griner maybe a newfound appreciation and
love for the country that just put its
own safety at risk for the sake of
relieving her of the consequences of her
own stupidity
one might hope that she will come home
and stand with pride with her hand over
her heart the next time the anthem is
played
but one would have to have been born
yesterday to believe any of that Harbor
those delusions
I mean she's certain to come home
you know return to us more committed to
our own self-victimization and personal
resentments than ever before
and Paul Whalen a man who loves his
country
but has been forsaken by it
we'll just continue to sit
and wait
now let's get to our five headlines
if you're a small business owner you
know how important it is to prepare for
the holiday season if you haven't
started preparing for the chaos of
holiday mailing and shipping well you're
already way behind luckily stamps.com
has everything you need to make your
life much easier sign up now and you'll
be printing your own postage in minutes
stamps.com is a One-Stop shop for all
your shipping and mainly needs is a 24 7
post office that you can access from
anywhere no lines no traffic no hassle
for 20 years stamps.com has been
indispensable for over 1 million
businesses get access to the USPS and
UPS services that you need to run your
business right from your computer even
save up to 86 86 percent on USPS and UPS
shipping rates use stamps.com to print
postage wherever you do business all you
need is a computer and a printer and if
you need a package picked up you can
easily schedule it through your
stamps.com dashboard so get ahead of the
holiday chaos this year get started with
stamps.com today sign up with promo code
Walsh for a special offer that includes
a four-week trial plus free postage and
a free digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com Click the microphone at the
top of the page and enter code Walsh
uh also you know it's not just
Paul Whalen who's still sitting in a
Russian prison there's also a guy named
Mark Fogle who is uh who's who's been in
a Russian prison
for I believe over a year now and uh for
and and he was given a 14-year sentence
and here they're the uh this maybe isn't
even in some ways the fact that Fogle is
still sitting in in a Russian prison in
some ways is even more outrageous
because what the Bible Administration
will try to claim and its Defenders are
already claiming you know that you heard
him say it he said well they're treating
uh Paul Whalen as a as a completely
different case and so they're the ones
this is on them uh they consider him
because they call they think he's a spy
so they consider him a lot more
important and so they're not going to
give them up uh unless we give up
somebody important well meanwhile we
just gave up the most notorious arms
trafficker in history so you would think
that there would be they'd be able to
work something out there
um but but Fogel Mark Vogel
was not convicted of uh by by the
Russian court system of Espionage that's
not what he suspected of uh this it was
a very similar case this was uh he was
arrested because of
because of violating their drug laws
Mark fogle's A a teacher spent 10 years
teaching in Russia then left and came
back
and he had a relatively small amount of
medical marijuana that have been
prescribed to him because of severe a
severe back injury that he had suffered
and a lot of botched surgeries and so on
so he had chronic severe pain he had
been prescribed medical cannabis
um legitimately prescribed it you know
he could produce the prescription from
the doctor and he had that with him and
he was caught at the airport with it and
they convicted him of being a drug
Smuggler and they sent him to prison for
14 years and he's now sitting he's now
at he's now at a labor camp and keep in
mind this is a guy with chronic severe
back pain
he certainly doesn't have his medicine
anymore and he's at a labor camp
he wasn't included in this deal
same exact kind of charge
not included
not only that but as as far as I'm aware
and in the most recent article I could
find about this
um dates back to November about a month
ago
as of early November
the Dubai Administration will not even
designate Mark Fogle as wrongfully
detained
they designated Brittany Greiner as
being wrongfully detained even though
she did she violated Russian law
but by our standards we decided she's
wrongfully detained Mark Vogel also did
violate Russian law uh because it was a
this is in the United States where we
have medical cannabis in Russia they
either don't have that at all or it's
just this didn't qualify
but so but why doesn't he get the
wrongful detainment designation
and because they don't qualify as
wrongfully detained they're not even
trying to bring him home
you know as of uh
early November you know there were
republicans in Congress trying to get
the bite administration at least to
explain why produced documents
explaining why they're not even trying
with Fogel why isn't he considered
wrongfully attendant they won't do it
so he's sitting in prison
Mark Fogle Paul Whalen
there are some similarities here between
you know you you could you could start
looking at patterns
and one of the mistakes one of the big
mistakes that uh what's what's a what's
a mistake that both Mark Fogle and Paul
Whalen made
well they both made the mistake of being
straight white men
you know that's that's one mistake that
they made
far be it for me to suggest that people
in that category when it comes to
getting Aid and help from the bite
Administration far be it for me to for
me to suggest that uh that people in
that category are put at the back of the
line I mean I'm only suggesting it
because this has been the Biden
Administration policy on record they
gave out covet assistance based on uh
along racial lines and put the white
people in the back of the line
so it seems to be a very similar thing
happening here
all right but will this we talk about
Brittany grinder coming home will she
appreciate America now of course she
won't will she at least now be willing
to concede that she is not being
systemically a persecuted based on her
race and gender given the fact that you
know you've got three potential
Americans that could come home two of
them straight white men one a gay black
woman and she gets to come home and they
stay so will she then at least say you
know what maybe but because of my
sexuality and gender and and uh and race
I'm not actually being oppressed in this
country I mean I I was prioritized and
I'm a home free now and they're still
rotting in prison will she at least
concede that of course she won't
all right
so the daily wire has a story the dean
of students at an elite private school
in Chicago was allegedly recorded on
undercover video admitting to having a
group come into his classroom and pass
out sex toys during Pride week for
students to examine and to learn about
gay sex the video was captured by the
conservative action group project
Veritas post on social media Wednesday
evening
the video allegedly shows Joseph Bruno
dean of students at the Francis W Parker
school which cost tens of thousand
dollars to attend telling an undercover
activists for project Veritas about
activities that take place in his
classroom
uh we have the video which went uh
massively viral online uh thanks thanks
in part to the fact that Elon Musk has
allowed project Veritas to get back on
Twitter which there was no reason for
them to be kicked off Twitter the only
reason they were ever kicked off Twitter
is uh this is actually one of the most
outrageous examples of someone getting
banned from Twitter because the only
thing they ever did wrong was just
producing video that that that uh
embarrassed the left now they're back on
there they released this video so let's
let's watch
some of those go ahead
I had like our lgbtq plus Health Center
come in they were passing around butt
plugs and dildos to my students talking
about queer sex using blue versus using
spit meet Joe Bruno dean of students at
the prestigious branches W Parker
private school in Chicago which happens
to charge forty thousand dollars per
student they're just like passing on
dildos butt plugs the kids are just
playing with them they're like how do
you how does this work how do I do like
how does this work that's a really like
a blue part of my job parents might be
stunned to learn that Bruno's version of
love and acceptance means handing out
sex toys to underage students for four
years during Pride we do a pride week
every year and I had
um
I had like our lgbtq plus Health Center
come in they were passing around butt
plugs and dildos to my students talking
about queer sex using blue versus using
spit who is this this is uh the lgbtq
plus Health Center came in to talk to my
high school students they're just like
passing our dildos butt plugs the kids
are just playing with them they're
looking at them in the school in a
classroom wow yeah well I'm sitting
there and we had a drag queen come in
pass out cookies and brownies and do
photos
and everybody's cool with that like the
clouds and the dildos nobody complaints
I mean if the parents found out what
they you know
queer sex this is the drag queen that
came in what's her name uh Alexis bevels
Alexis bevels and just hung out in my
classroom and was there girl hung out in
my office you have so much freedom and
so much
wiggle room
so much money I mean [ __ ] Bluetooth
stuff these are okay with that too oh
yeah
they don't know okay
so much Freedom so much money
uh
so it's got drag queen coming and just
just hanging out
hanging out in his office too he's uh I
wonder what they're up to
so he's he's got the cross-dressing
fetishes coming into the the classroom
um
and somehow that's not the most
outrageous thing that he's doing because
he is also having groups come in and
pass out sex toys to the children so
that they can according to him
play with the sex toys
uh during class
this is
a confession of uh sexual abuse
this is a confession of pedophilic
sexual abuse
by this monstrous
piece of garbage
and uh after this video came out how has
how how has this this school that people
are spending parents are spending tens
of thousand dollars to send their kids
to how did they respond well the first
thing they did was that they deleted
their Twitter account because that's
what you do when you're innocent right
the very first thing you do is you just
take everything down
uh very similar to I remember what
Vanderbilt did when we uh uh blew the
lid off of uh what was happening there
very first thing they did was they just
took down their entire website that
deals with gender transitions the gender
Clinic took it all down
um
yeah a real sign of Innocence there and
shortly thereafter we had this from
lives with Tick Tock had this update
Francis W Parker school in Chicago
Illinois where the dean of students
Joseph Bruno was caught on video uh
talking about giving students butt plugs
and dildos sent out this email to
parents saying that they stand in full
support of the dean
so this is the email that they sent out
we're ready to let you know that one of
our employees while at a conference last
week was targeted by a right-wing Fringe
group of individuals that seek to
undermine and manipulate diversity
Equity inclusion and belonging work in
schools
because when you're given out butt plugs
to kids to play with
that's just inclusion and belonging
this evening the group showed up outside
the school attempted to confront and
Ambush this employee with aggressive
questions a handful of students and
family members were present this
incident is very upsetting and we stand
in full support of our employee we have
put additional security measures in
place and we will notify the community
should there be any additional activity
from this group regarding the school of
uh regarding the school or our employee
we advise members of our community not
to engage with any organization that
fits this General profile
this is from Dan Frank the principal
don't engage with any organization
otherwise otherwise known as keep your
mouth shut
don't don't talk to anybody about this
um because this is uh this is just the
tip of the iceberg
can you imagine what else is going on
inside the school
I mean this is what this guy was willing
to admit to
now he truly didn't know he was being
recorded but he was sitting in a crowded
conference talking very openly about
this
so this is the stuff that we know about
um
they don't want us to find out about the
things we don't know about yet
and what do they do they they
immediately Circle the wagon around this
sexual abuser
and meanwhile we will be told that you
know the claim that there is sexual
grooming going on in the classroom is
some sort of it's all it's all a myth
it's a right-wing
fairy tale
like none of this is going to stop until
a guy like uh this this groomer this
pedophile
until someone like Joseph Bruno
you know until we have armed police
officers
busting into his home in the middle of
the night guns drawn
and frog marching him into a jail cell
okay in handcuffs until that is what
until that is the response none of this
stops
and I said that last night on Twitter
and of course someone did correct me and
say well no no we don't want the police
to uh bust into the house of middle
night we want to be in the middle of the
day
or maybe come into the school and start
dragging people out because we want this
to be visible to everybody we want
people to see it and that's true so I'll
take that correction yeah in fact not
middle of the night I prefer for it to
be in the middle of the day
and frog marched in front of jeering
crowds
heaping contempt
on this monstrous piece of crap
but our government and uh and you know
law enforcement agencies
they Reserve that kind of treatment for
pro-life activists
that's what happens to pro-life
activists in Philadelphia
they get pulled out of their homes at
gunpoint in the middle of night in
handcuffed and brought to jail
whereas men who admit to sexual abuse
this is sexual abuse if and there would
be no question about it I mean there's
no question about it here but
you take this out of the classroom
and you have this Joseph Bruno
um child groomer showing up to like a a
playground or a park or something
with a with a satchel full of dildos and
butt plugs and handing them out to the
children
everyone would agree that this guy is a
pedophile and needs to be charged with
sexual abuse and thrown in prison for
the rest of his life
but you take that you put it into a
classroom and suddenly it's it's well
it's totally different so different
different rules entirely
but maybe I'm giving the left too much
credit I mean I I I'm assuming that if
this guy was doing this with random kids
at a playground that they would that
even they would admit that it's
inappropriate at a minimum I'm not sure
if they would
remember as you've heard from me so many
times you talked about it what does a
woman uh you gotta you gotta know where
this stuff comes from you have to
understand
uh where it all originates where it's
coming from
and this all this all goes back to
Alfred Kinsey and the effort to
sexualize children from birth and you
know he's yet another disciple of this
and the entire left they're all
Disciples of this uh of of that same
religion
and so they just don't they don't object
they have no problem with this
all right next we have this this would
uh
seem to be entirely real sadly and this
is a post from an account called pup
ravage
and here's the post
it says
uh well after nearly three decades in
uniform this all army dog is finally
done as of today he's Colonel ravaged
U.S army retired it's been a great run
okay just by like reading that to you
he's like well there's nothing wrong
with that
um but then you see this this man in a
uh
dog-themed bondage gear wearing a
wearing a dog mask and his military
uniform and this was posted
um
on Twitter and under this post which has
since been put to private there were
other military guys in leather dog
bondage gear and their military uniforms
wearing the the two things at the same
time responding enthusiastically and
positively the whole uh Paw Patrol gang
came out to voice their approval
there was another post from a guy says
congratulations sir you earned it
salutes and he also has his bondage gear
his puppy mask along with his uh his
military dress uniform
now needless to say right these guys
should be arrested arrested and here's
more more people that could be arrested
and thrown in prison uh that should be
the penalty for posing with your bondage
gear while in military uniform
but I bring this up because it might
help explain this this is a recent
report from an ABC affiliate in Detroit
says for many who join the art the armed
services is a chance to serve their
country enjoy decent benefits and in
some cases even see the world but right
now as we Mark Veterans Day the U.S
military is facing a problem not enough
people are signing up it was a concern
that took the spotlight in late
September during a senate committee
hearing
Senator Kirsten gillibrand said by the
end of 2022 the active U.S military will
be at its smallest size since the
creation of the all-volunteer force
Antonio Andrews is a Sergeant First
Class in the Army Reserves however uh
and right now he's on active duty we
spoke with him from Fort Bliss Texas he
said quote I've been in 36 years
straight out of high school
um he says I wanted to do my part
he talks about the recruitment video he
saw before he signed up he says quote
music was playing the guys was running
up on the tanks and throwing grenades
shooting off weapons and I was like sign
me up I'm ready
during the Senate hearing on September
21st Army leadership warned that just 23
of Americans 17-24 are even qualified to
serve data from the Department of
Defense provided to action news shows
that as of August 2022 the Army was on
track to be short of its enlistment goal
by around 15 000 soldiers
okay so that's kind of interesting right
so you got the army guy there that they
talked to he's been in three and a half
decades and uh and what is it that
convinced him to join well it was a in
part a recruitment ad with tanks and
explosions and cool music and the
promise that he could serve his country
and fight some bad guys that's what
that's what motivated him to serve
now and that has motivated it's not just
one recruit recruitment ad obviously but
it's that's the that's the kind of thing
that motive that has motivated young men
to serve in the military
how many people are signing up though
because they want to serve alongside dog
fetishes and BDSM Kink enthusiasts
how many are signing up for that how
many are signing up because they really
want to take diversity training
and learn about tolerance and
inclusivity
how many people are in that category
like nobody wants that no one is signing
up for that and if there are a few
people who would sign up for it they're
exactly the sorts of people you don't
want
so you see here the military is making
the same mistake that churches have made
and uh and really military and Church
These are not so dissimilar in terms of
Form and Function because military you
fight physical battles against physical
enemies and uh in church you fight
spiritual battles against spiritual
enemies and churches have seen their
attendance crater as they've moved away
from their calling to engage in
spiritual warfare and instead they've
adopted this feminized approach they've
feminized the service they've made
everything more open and tolerant and
effeminate and they've done that
and as they've done it people have been
driven away in droves
this change was made in order to bring
more people in the doors they said well
if we're more open and more welcoming
we've tone things down a little bit
um and and everything's a lot more
gentle and womanly if we do that then
more people will want to come to church
and what they found is at the exact
opposite is the case and I think a
similar thing is happening in the
military
um
why
well because for the military
almost no young man actually desires to
commit himself to a woke institution
like this
wokeness doesn't speak to any of the
real desires of the Soul
for a man or for a woman
and and the thing is if if he does
desire wokeness if this is what he wants
if he wants hyper tolerance uh this you
know focus on diversity and equity and
all the rest of it
why would he go to the military
see that's the problem most young men
don't want this nonsense and won't sign
up for it and the ones who do why would
they sign up for the military to get it
because if if diversity and inclusion
are and all that kind of stuff if that's
important to you you can go anywhere
else and get that why the military
the military is trying to compete with
like Starbucks now
because it's saying hey uh you need to
make some money you need something to do
you need a job and you want to be part
of a woke institution come join the Army
but the woke people are saying why I
could just be a barista but there's less
commitment
the wokeness is more authentic
and meanwhile all the men who want
nothing to do with any of that are
scared away
all right what else we have I've had
this clip uh sitting here for a couple
days that I've wanted to play Richard
AKA Rachel Levine of Health and Human
Services is now urging pediatricians to
be trans activists let's listen to a
little bit of that
so I encourage all of you to think of
yourselves as ambassadors to your
communities
ambassadors for science
ambassadors for compassion
and ambassadors for care
these conversations don't have to be
limited or restricted to a medical
setting offered yourselves as
informational resources not just for
youth but for school teachers principals
school boards professional organizations
recreation centers
County Commissioners and others who
would benefit from this information in
your perspective
please proactively seek opportunities to
speak about what you know our task is to
educate the public in as many forms as
possible
we need to have these conversations that
question the assumptions that are
underlying today's attacks on trans
people pushing back the veil of
ignorance demands this extra effort and
this is a this is the challenge before
our profession for almost 40 years now
I have considered an honor to be a
doctor
I believe in our role as healers I
believe in our role as truth tellers
and the truth that we need to confront
now is that medicine and science are
being politically perverted around this
country this destroys human lives and we
have reached a Tipping Point for the
role in the medicine and Civic life
for the health and well-being of lgbtqi
plus youths uh Rachel quote on quote
unquote Rachel is concerned that
medicine and science is being perverted
it is exactly right it is it is being
both of those things are being
horrifically perverted
um to a catastrophic extent by him and
by people like him
as we continue to be such an utter joke
on the world stage I mean we heard so
much about this during during Trump's uh
Administration the left was very
concerned media is very concerned about
how the rest of the World Views us and
we're losing respect on the world stage
and there wasn't a lot of evidence that
was actually happening during the Trump
Administration but but you know if
you're concerned about the world stage
and how they view US
what do you think they think
when they see Rachel Levine
Admiral Rachel Levine
as one of the was one of the most high
profile people in the administration
this man cosplaying as a woman
and now we're giving up you know arms
traffickers for WNBA players and all the
rest of it
you know we talked about yesterday about
there's uh this epidemic of people drop
essentially dropping out of society and
they're not dropping all the way out
because they're still living off of the
fruits of modern society and enjoying
all those and they're sitting in their
homes and they have their phones and
they're watching Netflix and all that
they're playing video games and they're
uh and they're eating fast food so
they're very much still in modern
society but they're not participating in
it they're not contributing to it we
talked about what what what's lurking
behind that what's the reason for that
and there are a lot of reasons that we
went over but um
on top of everything we talked about
yesterday the other thing too is that
people are losing
faith in our institutions they don't
trust any of the institutions anymore
and in for no institution is that is
that is that more clear than with the
Medical Institution
because of people like Rachel Levine
who are working every day to turn
pediatricians into trans activists
that's why people are losing faith
all right let's get now to the comment
section
big dumpy white guy says in response to
a comment from yesterday's show my son
was constantly being diagnosed with ADHD
by his kindergarten teachers in the
resulting parent teacher meetings I
would tell them that they were not
qualified to make this diagnosis and I
would always resist their impassioned
pleas of before it's too late like
what's too late third grade I did end up
relenting around third grade and allowed
him to be medicated on the lowest dose
of concerta for almost uh concerto I
think it's not pronounce for almost a
year before I discontinued it because he
told me that he didn't like it I never
allowed it to be made known to the
school
and therefore there was pushback when I
made that decision anyways some somehow
he's growing up just fine and he hasn't
committed any violent offenses such as
misgendering any of his classmates I
appreciate your support surrounding ADHD
slash normal boys Behavior SPG for life
uh well I'm happy to hear that he's that
uh you've gotten him off these drugs and
I'm also happy to hear that you resisted
the the uh the call to put them on the
drugs in kindergarten
um I will say though if he's not
misgendering his classmates yet then you
got to work on that because he needs to
be doing that but other than that it's a
it's a good thing and it's just
the the idea
that
this kind of thing can be quote
diagnosed in kindergarten is obviously
Madness and you're right that the
kindergarten teachers aren't qualified
to diagnose a kindergartner
with ADHD
but I would also add that nobody is
qualified to diagnose that
I I you know I don't care as
kindergarten teacher psychiatrist
psychiatrist psychologist therapist I
don't care who it is
nobody is qualified
to declare that a five-year-old boy has
a deficiency of attention
especially when no one's been able to
explain what exactly the hell that means
deficient in attention
for what what is the correct amount of
attention that a five-year-old boy is
supposed to have
is it the same in all such like his
ability to pay attention when you're a
five-year-old boy the ability to pay
attention is is largely dependent on
what we're asking him to pay attention
to isn't it
not just for five-year-old boys but for
kids of any age
you know the other the other fascinating
thing is that uh you want to hear about
ajd and uh kids they can't pay attention
they can't pay attention
uh they can't pay attention in school
they can't but you never hear parents
complaining that kids can't pay
attention to the video games
right even the ones that are most cursed
with ADHD they could sit down in front
of a video game and play it for hours
right they look at their phone for hours
you pay attention to that
oh so no they can sit still and pay
attention to things it's just that if
the thing is boring
then it's harder to get them to pay
attention to it
that sounds to me like a kid
scratch that that sounds to me like a
person all people are like that it's
very hard to pay attention to boring
things
but if you put something in front of
someone that they're interested in and
they find entertaining and they have no
trouble
um
all right
Jim says if Charlie Brown doesn't get
good enough at football Lucy is never
going to stop pulling the ball away
God bless you Matt but it's going to
take more than playing their game by
their rules that they can change
whenever they have to to win this
someone is already on the inside is
going to have to stand up and make
things happen however they can
all right Jim I I get that but so so
what's your solution here okay I mean
what exactly is your solution
when it comes to voting mail and voting
exists
um early voting exists all these things
exist they are systems that are in place
they are being exploited and used by the
Democrats to win elections and so
what are what are you saying that we
should just refuse to take advantage of
these systems and only allow the
Democrats to do it
thereby signing our own political death
warrant it's political suicide as you
say well someone on the inside needs to
stand up and make it happen so we're
just going to So the plan is to sit
around waiting for quote someone on the
inside to solve it who on the inside I
mean this is a problem in in every state
so just we need some magical person in
every state to do this
how do you get the person whoever is on
the inside and solve how do they get
there
that you got to vote them there it's not
gonna get there otherwise
I mean if you're talking about someone
on the inside like the president of the
United States
um if you need you know we need a
Republican president if you're saying we
need Donald Trump back in the office
2024 if that's what you mean they got to
be voted in
and they're not going to get in there
unless we start exploiting these systems
that are in place
whether we like it or not and we don't
like it but it's it's it is just the
reality
it's it's amazing to me that we even
have to talk about this
like the Democrats have given themselves
an advantage
and we have the opportunity to exploit
that same exact system and there are
actually people saying we shouldn't do
it
uh it's to me it's a total Madness
all right one other thing this from Ben
says Matt what are your thoughts on the
Dion Sanders situation I know you're a
football fan would love to hear your
take so I haven't really followed the
story all I know is that Deion Sanders
was coaching at a smaller school had a
lot of success then got a job offer at
Colorado uh which is a bigger school but
a program that's in disarray and he's
going to go there now and try to turn
the program around do kind of Remember
the Titans deal minus the racial aspects
of that and I guess he gave he gave a
speech to his new players a couple days
ago and the speech has been
controversial I suppose some sports
media folks didn't like the speech they
thought it was I don't know we have a
clip of that let's uh watch it
I just want you to know
okay
not to compete but to win
not to show up but to show up
not to be amongst the rest but to be the
best
I'm coming
I'm flat outcome this is real this ain't
no ESPN or this ain't one of the
networks you just happened to see man
I'm right in front of you you know why
because I'm coming
I'm coming to restore to replace and
re-energize some of y'all that are
salvageable I'm not gonna lie everybody
to see they put in the seat ain't gonna
have no seat when we get back
but I'm coming
uh I started and we gonna go dominate
then we gonna work I'm coming to work
and not to play it I'm coming to kill it
and not to kick it
I'm coming
so you gotta understand so when I get
back ain't gonna be no hats no means
ain't gonna be no hoodies on and no Bees
ain't gonna be no phones I wish you
would bring the phone in my meat it
ain't gonna be no earrings into me
everybody's gonna look like everybody
I'm coming it's going to be a different
place a different feel a different
attitude a different energy a different
work ethic a different one A different
hunger a different desire a different
need
a different capacity it's gonna be a
different reach
I'm cutting
I don't know what the indictment of
Deion Sanders is supposed to be as I
said I I haven't really followed the
story there may be context I'm missing
but I listen to that and I love that I
mean it's a little bit me centered okay
he says I a bit too much he's very you
know it's so it's me but this is Deion
Sanders it's a stick the basic message
is terrific I mean it's got uh exactly
the right amount of that kind of
military Unity going to war discipline
uh at least these are messages we used
to associate with the military it's got
that feel to it and and and uh and I
think it's I think it's great he's
telling it was like some of you guys
aren't going to be here if you can't cut
it don't wear hats in my meetings don't
bring phones in here I don't want to see
earrings like you know everybody looks
like everybody that's that is what it's
supposed to be you know that's
traditionally football's always had this
it's not the military obviously they're
not actually going to war but uh people
that are ex football players we don't
call them veterans but
although we don't call them combat
veterans but it has that
it it has that kind of traditionally
it's had that kind of feel and tone
um with it with an intense focus on on
discipline and unity everybody looks
like everybody you're one unit it's not
about the individual that's what
football is supposed to be
and the and the way that traditionally
football coaches talk about they do talk
about it like we're going to war we're
going to battle
so it makes football football and it's
it's it's what makes it good for young
men even with the physical risks I know
these days we get very squeamish you
know there are some
risks that many parents are willing to
take with their children I think we get
it exactly backwards you know parents
are willing to take risks with their
kids
you give your nine-year-old a phone
you're taking a big risk you're taking a
risk with your with your nine-year-old's
mind and soul
so we're willing to risk that so we'll
risk the child's mind and soul but we
don't want to risk their physical safety
we don't want to take any risks on the
physical safety so that means don't
climb the tree too high don't play
football Don't Play Rough Sports
I think it should be the other way
around
I mean guard and cherish your child's
mind and soul but allow your child to
take physical risks within reason
obviously and in controlled environments
especially with boys if you don't allow
that if you don't allow if you don't
allow them to take
reasonable measured physical risks
then um and you don't provide them an
environmental controlled environment to
take those risks and to get out all that
aggression then they're going to find
another outlet for it and instead of you
know because they can't play football
they're going to next thing you know
they're going to be 17 years old uh you
know driving down a back road at 95
miles an hour
to run into a tree and kill themselves
like those that's that's the kind of
risk they're going to take instead
um
and so I think that's what that's why
football is is good for young especially
young men who don't have father figures
in the house
they don't have male role models
it's a great outlet for that
so I think that's great from Deon
Sanders I'm a big fan of that
all over the country wives mothers
sisters daughters are standing up for
the strong men and boys in their lives
by kicking woke razor companies out of
his bathroom and replacing them with
Jeremy's razors Jeremy's razors is a
premium Men's Grooming company that's
shockingly doesn't hate men the
Precision five razor will trim his beard
not his masculinity and the new
American-made hair body and skin care
line has got his whole routine covered
it's a win-win uh you love that he's
cleaning up without parabens or sulfates
I don't know what the hell of paraben is
he loves that he's supporting a company
that doesn't hate his guts so everyone
wins Jeremy's razors is 100 woke free
and now 30 off when you order by
December 15th other so-called men's care
Brands work to make men feel bad
Jeremy's uh just wants them to look
great doesn't matter how you feel that's
irrelevant and so do you so kick woke
companies out of this bathroom this
Christmas go to dailywire.com Walsh
today and get 30 off the gift bundle now
let's get to our daily cancellation
foreign
there are many shall we say strange
things about male Tick-Tock star Dylan
Mulvaney who has amassed a million
dollar Fortune from endorsement deals
ever since deciding that he wants to
pretend that he's a woman perhaps the
weirdest aspect of Mulvaney's uh very
profitable
Woman face charade is his obsession with
tampons products that those of us with a
male and atomical structure have no use
for and Mulvaney has a male anatomical
structure because he is again a male no
matter how often or how obnoxiously he
claims the contrary yet much is revealed
here I think about the trans phenomenon
and all of it is extremely bizarre and
disturbing so backing up for a moment in
April
Mulvaney who's still in the early days
then of his uh days of girlhood stick
recounted an alleged incident that
sparked his resolve
to always carry tampons
listen
stage 12 of being a girl and I just
picked up some tampons and y'all are
probably thinking Dylan where are you
gonna put those they're not for me but
this last weekend I was in the restroom
and the girl in the stall next to me was
like hey do you have a tampon and I
froze I was like sorry no but in that
moment I decided you know what I'm
always gonna have one on hand for anyone
who needs it you come over to my house
and we're having a glass of wine I got a
tampon for you if we're in the club
together and then we go to the bathroom
I got a tampon for you women supporting
women love ya
now I confess that I have
um no personal first-hand knowledge of
what goes on inside a woman's bathroom
because I'm a man just like this guy the
only difference is that one of us
respects a woman's right to privacy and
the other one of us is Dylan Mulvaney
all that to say if I had to guess
I would suspect that a woman shouting to
a stranger in the next stall asking for
a tampon
is not a normal occurrence it reminds me
of the Seinfeld scene where Elaine asks
for her asks her stall neighbor for some
toilet paper something that I've never
personally heard or seen anyone do in
real life ever and if I were ever on the
receiving end of such a request in a
public bathroom I would consider it a
horrendous breach of public bathroom
etiquette
yeah perhaps these kinds of exchanges do
happen sometimes in the women's restroom
I don't know it's just interesting that
Dylan Mulvaney had quote been a girl for
like 12 days and had already encountered
that
but whether he made it up or not
the point is that he decided to always
carry tampons around for any woman who
might need it he expected that women his
fellow women as he considers them would
fall over themselves to thank and
congratulate him for volunteering to be
a tampon Repository
but instead actual women just found the
whole thing very creepy and gross
and Dylan felt offended by that he felt
offended that women were not more
appreciative of his acts of tampon
charity and that led to this video
posted this week
day 271 of being a girl or I'll say
woman for this one because this video is
for the women on Twitter who just really
don't like me hello ladies we got a lot
to cover but let's first talk tampons I
haven't talked about tampons on here
lately because I don't use them I'm a
woman who doesn't have a uterus I know
this and science was my strongest
subject in high school I was also
shockingly good at math but I digress I
just sometimes carry one in case anybody
needs it and that seems to have just set
the world on fire in some pretty nasty
ways
and this is a conversation that's been
going on for months I just haven't
chimed in because I'm so tired of
sticking up for myself over something
that was so pure intentioned but now
Twitter is just a blaze the bigger
problem at hand is that you feel me
carrying a tampon around is a threat to
you and your Womanhood
how is someone doing something nice so
repulsive to you
because listen to this if a man whether
he was your boyfriend or your husband
could even be your gay best friend kept
a tampon for you at his house just in
case he needed it you'd gush over him
you would run to brunch on Sunday and
tell all your gal Pals that he's so
thoughtful and he cares and he listens
and then a trans woman does it and all
of a sudden I'm the reason that there's
a tampon shortage you know it's it's not
because I'm misogynistic it's because
you're transphobic
you know we gotta work through this and
and babe caring for others it's the bare
minimum
yeah babe you know we all know that you
ladies are running to your Sunday brunch
and your fancy hats gushing to your gal
Pals about how your boyfriend walks
around in a fanny pack stuff with
tampons just in case you have a
menstrual emergency when he's around
um you notice how Mulvaney's vision of
Womanhood is almost entirely derived
from Sex in the City episodes this is
one of the most glaring truths about
transgenderism the men who identify as
women are not only not women they also
understand women far less
than the average man who identifies as
what he actually is
like this dude knows a lot less about
women than I do or like any a normal man
especially a married man
so we're not women but we've been around
them we're married to one so we have
some sort of insight
this guy just doesn't understand women
at all
trans women know know vastly less about
women have a have a much you know
inferior understanding of Womanhood
so I may not have women totally figured
out but I do know that first of all most
of them aren't going to Sunday brunch in
the first place and if they do they
aren't talking about their boyfriends
and husbands attitudes towards tampons
in fact if I may be so presumptuous I'm
going to assume that almost every woman
on the planet would be deeply creeped
out if the men in their lives walked
around with extra tampons on hand all
the time
I can tell you that my wife has been to
brunch with the gal Pals which she would
never call them that by the way ever
um like maybe twice in the last decade
she's been to a Sunday brunch and if I
ever pulled a tampon out of my pocket
and asked her if she needed it she would
look at me with a mixture of confusion
and horror and she would assume that I
had gone completely insane there would
be no gushing to the gal Pals about it
you know she might bring it up to a
female friend but it would be like in a
hushed and concerned sort of tone like
he had tampons in his pocket How
concerned should I be about this
and but by the way also whatever
happened to listening to women right so
we're supposed to listen to him so
Dylan Mulvaney thinks that women should
be appreciative of the tampon thing
he's admitting that the women are
telling him uh no thanks please don't
please stop doing this this is weird
just we don't need just stop by you
don't need to worry about the tampons
let us figure that out
and and rather than listening to the
women who are telling him what they want
he says well you should know you should
want something else
because the other thing you notice about
how Milton about this uh tampon Saga
with Dylan Mulvaney aside from the fact
that he's trying to become a woman and
yet has apparently never met one it's
also how condescending and patronizing
and threatening he is to the very people
he's trying to emulate
trans identifying men are very much
executing a hostile takeover of
Womanhood
and though he cloaks his condescension
and insults in a very thin veil of faux
kindness
it all still comes through loud and
clear especially at the end listen to
what he says at the end
P.S I am also very nervous for you just
because
hopefully soon transphobia won't be as
tolerated online but your tweets are
forever and I don't want those to come
back and haunt you
okay
bye
he's nervous for you
he's trying to look out for you ladies
he's just concerned that he
he might have to ruin your life over
wrong think he loves you he's your
friend he cares for you so much and he
really doesn't want to have to destroy
you for expressing Politically Incorrect
ideas he doesn't want to have to do it
it would hurt him more than it would
hurt you
he would hate it if your defense of
biological reality came back to haunt
you
man would he hate that
so shut your mouth
get in line
let him use your bathroom and locker
rooms all he wants
let him appropriate woman who turned
into some kind of bizarre sex in the
city parody Let Him degrade your
femininity let him run around acting out
his tampon fetish let him do all of this
in front of you as a direct mockery of
you and do not object
because those objections might come back
to haunt you
this is the trans invasion of Womanhood
in a nutshell bizarre fetishistic
degrading condescending
push through with veiled threats and not
so veiled threats
so he's the perfect mascot in many ways
not of Womanhood
but of its Invaders and appropriators
and for that reason he is once again
today canceled
and I will do it for this portion of
shows mover to members block let's see
there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed